[Música]
Venezuela conmemora a los 10 años de la
muerte de Hugo Chávez con la presencia
de autoridades locales y extranjeras
creador de una corriente que lo
sobrevive una década después Chávez
continúa siendo el líder venezolano más
popular de un país sumido en una larga
crisis económica
este domingo se cumplen 70 años de la
muerte de Joseph en la plaza Roja de
Moscú decenas de personas rindieron
homenaje al líder soviético en un acto
organizado por el partido comunista ruso
tenemos análisis en esta edición
en Irán este fin de semana decenas de
menores Fueron hospitalizadas por
envenenamiento leve en escuelas
femeninas del país según informó el
Ministerio de salud iraní se han
registrado ataques contra niñas en 52
centros educativos de Irán desde
noviembre entrarán distintas voces
apuntan a grupos fundamentalistas que se
oponen a la educación de las menores
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
vasdeu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles empezamos esta edición con
información de América Latina este
domingo Venezuela conmemora los 10 años
de la muerte del presidente Hugo Chávez
con ceremonias en la capital en Caracas
en los actos de este domingo participan
familiares de Chávez y autoridades
locales pero también grandes figuras de
la izquierda latinoamericana como los
expresidentes de Bolivia Cuba y Honduras
Evo Morales Raúl Castro y Manuel Zelaya
además durante esta madrugada decenas de
venezolanos rindieron honores al
Comandante con una vigilia en el cuartel
de la montaña Ahí es donde descansa el
cuerpo de Chávez Quien murió recordemos
en 2013 víctima del cáncer
el chavismo sobrevive a la figura de
Hugo Chávez una década después de su
muerte el comandante fundador del
partido socialista de Venezuela continúa
siendo el político mejor valorado en
Venezuela con una 56% de popularidad
esto según una encuesta de Data análisis
citada por el periódico el país sin
embargo 23 años después de la Revolución
bolivariana el país está sumido en una
larga crisis económica nuestra
corresponsal en Caracas nos Explica cómo
se vive esta jornada de conmemoración en
la capital
esta movilización partió desde varios
puntos del Oeste de Caracas rumbo al
cuartel de la montaña donde reposan los
restos del fallecido presidente Hugo
Chávez en nuestro recorrido pudimos
constatar que ya no se trataban de
concentraciones multitudinarias como
antes se veían eran pocas personas
varias tiras durante todo el recorrido y
en su mayoría funcionarios públicos
identificados en sus logos con el
Ministerio de infraestructura de ciencia
y tecnología la cante B transporte entre
otros más temprano se realizó un
homenaje en el cuartel de la montaña una
ceremonia más privada que contó con la
participación de los familiares más
cercanos de Hugo Chávez su madre sus
hijos y también el alto mando militar y
ella estuvieron presentes los
expresidentes de Bolivia Evo Morales de
Honduras Manuel Zelaya de Cuba Raúl
Castro y el presidente de Nicaragua
Daniel Ortega en su discurso el hermano
Hugo Chávez Adán Chávez llamaba a la
unión como una forma de
homenajearlo las personas que participan
de esta movilización insisten en que el
legado de Chávez está más presente que
nunca sin embargo es una realidad y
analistas coinciden en que la
administración de Nicolás maduro ha
intentado apartarse de la imagen de
Chávez para construir su propio modelo
su propio lenguaje y su propio proyecto
hoy en día Venezuela es un país sumido
en una crisis económica importante donde
la mayor parte de la población no tiene
acceso a la canasta básica
continuamos en nuestra región según una
información adelantada por el periódico
peruano el comercio la fiscalía de Perú
citó a declarar a la presidenta Dina
boluarte Este martes 7 de marzo esto en
el marco de la investigación por la
mortal represión de las protestas
desatadas por el arresto de Pedro
Castillo el pasado 7 de diciembre desde
entonces recordemos miles de personas
salieron a las calles para rechazar la
figura de su sucesora Dina boluarte y
para reclamar nuevas elecciones según la
defensoría del pueblo de Perú al menos
60 personas han muerto en las protestas
el mismo día de la comparecencia de la
mandataria ante la fiscalía el congreso
retomará el debate sobre el adelanto de
las elecciones previstas de momento para
de gobierno cambiamos de información en
Rusia este domingo cientos de Seguidores
de Joseph stalin se reunieron en la
plaza Roja de Moscú para conmemorar los
70 años de su muerte en una ceremonia
organizada por el partido comunista ruso
durante tres décadas stalin lideró la
rápida industrialización de la unión
soviética y la victoria del ejército
rojo sobre los nazis en la Segunda
Guerra Mundial sin embargo también fue
responsable de la muerte de millones de
ciudadanos muchos de ellos fueran brunas
así como en los campos de trabajos
forzados conocidos Como gulags para
analizar la figura de stalin en nuestros
días Contamos con Zaira Badillo ella es
historiadora de Rusia y la unión
soviética Zaira Buenas tardes la saludo
quisiera empezar preguntándole por en la
sociedad civil rusa a grandes rasgos
Cuáles serían los distintos recuerdos
que perduran de stalin a día de hoy Y
cómo han variado en el tiempo desde su
muerte hasta la actualidad
digamos que la guerra es Ucrania ha
cambiado un poco la perspectiva de
staling en la en la sociedad rusa
podemos decir que Putin Hasta cierto
punto quiere equiparar el logro de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial El Triunfo de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial a manos de stalin
con la guerra que él Libra en Ucrania
contra occidente por lo tanto podemos
decir que en los noventa la figura de
stalink todavía sigue sigue haciendo muy
controversial pero ya después del 2010
2014 con la anexión de crimea vemos que
la figura de esta ley empieza a tener
como mayor importancia en la definición
de la identidad rusa no está dignación
Georgia es étnicamente georgiano como
usted muy bien dijo lideró la
industrialización de la unión soviética
y ganó la guerra de acuerdo a las
historiadores de la unión soviética en
la unión soviética la guerra se gana
gracias a la intervención de de su
estrategia pero
sí causó mucho malestar y mucho dolor en
millones de rusos en millones de de
distintas étnicas por la represión tan
aguda que cometió para controlar
toda la población la policía secreta de
stalin fue muy brutal persiguió a
cualquier disidente y no solamente eso
sino stalin se le considera a la persona
responsable por las hambrunas que sufrió
Ucrania en los treinta no que se le
llama holodomo No y se había considerado
como una hambruna que se hizo a
propósito para castigar un poco al
movimiento ucraniano
que tenía unos intereses nacionalistas
quería promover la identidad ucraniana y
se vio Hasta cierto punto como una forma
de castigar ese pueblo en los treinta y
murieron aproximadamente unos cinco seis
millones de campesinos y personas
ucranianas por lo tanto es una figura
muy controversial particularmente ahora
por un lado por su por su brutalidad
Pero por otro lado porque logró unificar
a la población soviética no solo rusa en
el momento de la de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial y por el triunfo que le a esa
sociedad En aquel momento y precisamente
respecto lo que apuntaba al principio de
su respuesta como en el marco de la
guerra en Ucrania Putin digamos en las
esferas más elevadas a del kremlin se
puede estar revisitando esta imagen de
stalin no esto sucedería solamente en
los digamos en los puestos de poder en
la imagen a política en la comunicación
política o también entre la sociedad
encontramos Este cambio en la percepción
del legado de stalin
nueva generación en la percepción
una modernizador un agente de Progreso y
una figura que consolidó el pueblo Ruso
y que se enfrentó a occidente Si vemos
bien que hoy Rusia Aparentemente está
aislada no a pesar de que tiene
contactos con China la India y otros
países está muy aislada de Europa y de
occidente y algo así se vivió en la
época de stalin no luego de la
revolución rusa Revolución bolchevique
en los veinte y los treinta pues la
unión soviética estaba básicamente
aislada de los distintas instituciones
internacionales por lo tanto se puede
pueden haber comparativas no entre ese
periodo y el periodo que se está
viviendo ahora así que me parece que a
pesar de que la figura de stalin entre
ciertos sectores de la población siempre
se vio con cierto respeto creo que luego
de la Guerra de Ucrania y luego de los
enfrentamientos a Ucrania en el 2014
pues Putin ha querido utilizar la imagen
de héroe de stalin y compararse con él
por lo tanto creo que ahora mismo en la
generación joven la interpretación de lo
que fue él para la sociedad rusa
cambiando contrario a otras generaciones
en los noventas o en el sesenta en los
setenta en donde a pesar de que se
consideraba estar en una figura
importante no se podía olvidar el dolor
no porque
vemos a los familiares no los
descendientes de aquellos que que
sufrieron en la represión y Aunque eso
se recuerda pues ya se está olvidando un
poco en los libros de historia que se
están publicando ahí en ruso se se
enfatiza más bien su rol como héroe y
como consolidar consolidar no eh la
sociedad y usted dice que Putin no se ha
querido comparar con él en cierta manera
y desde occidente también se han emitido
muchas comparaciones entre Putin y
stalin a raíz de la invasión de Ucrania
pero usted cree que hay planos hay
puntos realmente donde hacer esta
comparación entre los dos líderes
bueno Putin es un líder muy fuerte ha
querido unificar la sociedad detrás de
unos valores él considera son los
valores que representan a la sociedad y
la la iglesia ortodoxa rusa en contra a
lo que el proyecta como
el desvío moral de de occidente por lo
tanto hay una ideología detrás de eso
pero me parece que Putin no tiene la
capacidad ni el control que tuvo stalin
en su momento de la sociedad no está
Alguien fue atrás de todos sus
disidentes pero la población rusa luego
de los noventa y los dos mil es una
población muy diversa muy crítica que
tiene distintas opiniones y las hace
sentir y a pesar de que hay una gran
propaganda para para vender verdad este
discurso que viene de de Moscú Yo creo
que es una población más compleja y más
difícil de controlar contrario a los a
los años cuarenta donde está el sí tenía
el control
Zaira Lamentablemente se nos acaba el
tiempo para hablar de este tema tan
complejo y tan Interesante pero muchas
gracias por estar aquí con nosotros en
Franz 24 cambiamos a nosotros de
información porque en el nagorno caravag
este domingo tropas de azerbaiyán y de
Armenia se enfrentaron en un intercambio
de fuego que acabó con la vida de cinco
personas según informaron las
autoridades locales recordemos que la
región del nagorno caravag ha sido un
foco de tensiones entre las dos ex
repúblicas soviéticas de azerbaiyán y
Armenia desde el colapso de la unión
hace tres décadas población del pueblo
armenio vive en una zona reconocida
internacionalmente como territorio de
azerbaiyán ambos países se han
enfrentado en dos guerras la última en
2020 duró seis semanas vacuum recuperó
territorio a yerban y acabó con una
tregua y la presencia de tropas rusas en
la zona en misión de paz
en otras noticias en Irán siguen los
envenenamientos contra niñas en escuelas
de todo el país desde el gobierno de
Ibrahim Racing señalan a enemigos
exteriores pero otros funcionarios
apuntan a Ultra radicales religiosos en
contra del derecho a la educación de las
menores más detalles con Luis Muñoz
son niñas y están en un hospital en sus
cuerpos veneno ataques registrados en
más de 50 escuelas en al menos 21 de las
31 provincias de Irán era la clase de
Educación Física cuando fuimos al
pasillo olimos algo parecido a un
perfume tengo un entumecimiento muy
Severo en mi cuerpo no puedo caminar en
absoluto todas las estudiantes sintieron
los mismos síntomas que yo tenían todos
algunas dijeron que les ardían los ojos
y la mayoría estaban asustadas los
envenenamientos comenzaron en noviembre
en la ciudad Santa musulmana para los
chiítas de quam pero hasta hace unos
días no se anunció una investigación
Este es el último comunicado difundido
por el Ministerio del interior
la seguridad de los estudiantes es la
principal prioridad de los funcionarios
síntomas observados en 52 escuelas hasta
ahora la mayoría de las personas son
dadas de alta después de recibir
atención ambulatoria Ministerio de salud
anunciará los resultados de la
investigación pericial intentos del
enemigo de forzar el cierre de los
centros educativos
este último punto es al que dirigen los
focos los políticos iraníes
Por supuesto que a nuestros enemigos les
gusta causar disturbios en el país a
través de operaciones y ahora están
apareciendo una vez más para jugar con
las emociones del pueblo iraní e incitar
al miedo
pero otros señalamientos indican que
detrás estarían grupos radicales
religiosos que se oponen a la educación
de las niñas derecho que no había sido
puesto en duda en más de 40 años de
revolución islámica sin embargo esto ha
cambiado tras las protestas más grandes
en décadas con gran protagonismo de y
que dejan al menos 530 personas muertas
y la detención de alrededor de 20.000
personas según Human Rights active
cerramos con la noticia de un incendio
masivo que arrasó un campamento de
refugiados de personas de la comunidad
musulmana rojinya en el sur de
bangladesh el cuerpo de bomberos local
reportó que el fuego Ya está bajo
control y no ha causado víctimas
mortales por el momento según Naciones
Unidas más de un millón de refugiados
rojinya han migrado a bangladesh desde
myanmar durante décadas huyendo de la
represión militar contra su minoría
y aún así al final de esta emisión pero
sigan con nosotros en 34 y franken
34.com
[Música]